I love Manila and Naomi very much
Naomi's one of my really good friends
which is actually would even spark the
whole comment and my whole comments in
the first place is right you know I feel
like people should be wary of what their
write on the internet and not be racist
because racism is not cool it doesn't
matter who you are or what race you're
targeting just like it's just not cool
and it's not cool to have
microaggressions like to push narratives
just because you feel like you can't
drag race' la maza setting the record
straight after trolls came for them for
supporting Naomi smalls
after Naomi did this I'm so sorry that I
have to send home Manila I do have a
special love for Naomi I will jump from
a car for Naomi like I love her that
much you were joking about getting
cancelled because it's a comment you
made I just want to give you the
platform to say your piece on that whole
situation when you're a public figure
people take what you say out of context
it's sort of like I think you know fans
and board people want to be a part of a
conversation that honestly they were
really not supposed to be part of for
someone to accuse me of you know being
prejudice or or being any type of
malicious way towards people of color
sort of ironic
so I Know Who I am and I know what I
meant and I know what I mean and I don't
have any like mal-intent
so I really don't have an ending to
clear up I just want to say like you
know make sure you have your facts I am
a fan of this show I've always been a
fan of the show
so that doesn't change obviously when
you're on the show your view of the show
changes but I still have like a little
like a little like fan in me I can
totally like step back and then have my
fan conversations and then they'll
separate it from like my conversations
as a person is participated are you
rooting for Naomi
honestly I I don't really have an
opinion about the show because I kind of
don't care but I do I do like want all
of them to be successful and to utilize
their platforms and just like speak up
about the right things and just like you
know go as far as they can like
it we're also lucky to have been given
this platform and it's not being on the
show that really counts it's what you do
afterward
as for what Asha is doing after their
run on the show they just dropped their
first full-length album box office how
does it feel to have the record out
there for public consumption I still
can't believe it because it's sort of
like just yesterday I was listening to
it and showing all my close friends and
nobody in the world had heard it and now
it's like it's just out there and I
don't know it's surreal it's my first
big music project and I'm just really
excited to share it with the world
[Music]